aujourd'hui la frontière première partie
des finitions ouvrage de référence et à
les utiliser pour cette leçon front et
frontières de michel fougère frontières
au niveau écologique vient du masculin
feront front c'est le voeu la ligne de
front d'un point de vue militaire c'est
là où vous combat l'ennemi
évidemment avec le temps cette
connotation militaire s'est un peu perdu
et des frontières actuelles qui sont
bien paisible n'en reste pas moins
d'anciennes lignes de front ou
inversément des frontières qui était
autrefois paisible sont maintenant
devenus des zones de front pour sortir
de cette étymologie un peu trop
restrictives nous allons définir la
frontière par sa fonction pour nous la
frontière est une discontinuité
géopolitique à fonction de marquage réel
symbolique et imaginaire dans les slides
suivant nous allons développer chacun de
ces éléments
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne la
discontinuité géopolitique l'est
peut-être intéressant de rappeler ce
terme discontinuité c'est ce qui n'est
pas continue ce cessez ce qui marque une
différence géopolitique
on est ici à l'intersection entre la
géographie et la politique
cette discontinuité géopolitique va
d'abord créer une unité interne puisque
à l'intérieur d'une frontière on a
quelque chose de commun à partager
il ya donc une unité ça peut être par
exemple un passé commun une volonté de
vivre ensemble commune ou une langue ou
une religion ou une ethnie
cette unité va s'opposer à un extérieur
il ya donc une séparation la frontière
crée donc une séparation entre cette
unité est ce qui est différent
ce qu'une ce qui est discontinue mais
cette séparation n'est pas à distance
puisque la frontière va être aussi
l'endroit même où il ya un contact avec
ce différend nous avons envie en début
d'exploser que la frontière avait une
triple fonction
elle produit des effets sur le réel mais
aussi sur l'imaginaire et sur le
symbolique allons tout d'abord des
effets sur le réel par l'instauration
d'une frontière ont construit une limite
en deçà de laquelle une collectivité un
état une région un pouvoir politique
quelconque peu à exercer son autorité
c'est à dire que à l'intérieur de cette
frontière
on aura des lois particulières dès que
je passe la frontière
j'aurai des lois mais aussi des
règlements des usages les coutumes
différent si vous passez la frontière
franco belge
vous pourrez rouler à 130 kilomètres km
heure au lieu de 120 la limitation de la
vitesse sur toutes ses 120 km/heure en
belgique et en france c 130 km voilà la
frontière dès que vous passez la
frontière il ya un règlement différent
évidemment si vous faites arrêter en
belgique en roulant centre ans dans dix
ans mais je n'ai vu les trans l'agent
vous dira écoutez
oui si vous êtes passés en belgique donc
c'est la loi belge qui servent à la
frontière c'est aussi quelque chose de
très symbolique parce que si un état un
pays vient violé la frontière d'un autre
état sont mus demande et donc par
exemple imaginons que la france envoie
son armée en belgique
disons ça va créer un incident
diplomatique même plus que ça la
frontière même si on est en plein
terrain vague et que ce n'est qu'une
pressing et qui a rien
dès que vous la franchise et c'est comme
si vous à gressier le c'est pour cette
raison que l'on dit que la frontière a
des effets sur le symbolique puisqu'elle
symbolise par elle-même le pays où le
territoire acquis à la partie à la
frontière c'est aussi l'extérieur et
l'extérieur c'est l'étranger l'immigré
le réfugié qui va venir chez nous qui
colportent aussi quelques peurs des
représentations parfois vrai parfois
fausses la peur de l'étranger de
l'invasion
on va souvent parler des frontières en
termes d'ouvertures ou de fermeture
ce à quoi c'est tout un monde imaginaire
comme ça qui se construit autour de
cette frontière qui n'est pourtant
qu'une convention
voilà une cette vidéo est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de l'avoir
suivi je vous propose de répondre au
questionnaire et nous nous retrouvons en
place pour vos questions et les réponses